locataires
[musique]
nous l'avons
a été installé ici avec nous et les tapis étaient posés
les galons étaient nombreux dans les couloirs des courts
les miroirs étaient en très bon état
c'était pas cool
[musique]
oh je ne me souviens pas
Je vois
tout ce que tu n'as pas touché pendant que nous vivons encore
la fin du 19ème siècle, bien que dans la cour il semble être
vingt-et-unième siècle
près de tout nous sommes libres et le paysage
[musique]
Dis-moi qu'il y a deux camps seuls
croire que cet endroit est notre urbain
bidonvilles qui doivent être démolis et
cet endroit pour construire une résidence moderne
complexe d'autres comme je pense
qu'il s'agit d'un objet architectural unique
il faut le sauvegarder
restaurer et ainsi de suite
[musique]
J'ai choisi ce site parce qu'il
un endroit incroyable
une énergie incroyable, il y a un sentiment que
ici le temps d'une manière incroyable
arrêté
[musique]
Et
d'accord
[musique]